[Music]
I feel like a wallet that is just one of
the many reasons I'm team Miley on the
voice she's got the new show a new album
her engagement to Liam Hemsworth and I
gotta say her response to the pregnancy
rumors after she posted this pic is
still one of my favorites from all year
not pregnant
just eating a ton of tofurkey aren't we
all Miley so where'd she get that
attitude you'll see in this flashback we
call when we first met Miley this is
Miley this is Destiny Hope and this is
my little girl we call her Miley
[Music]
[Applause]
when we first met Miley she was three
and kind of shy but just two years later
hi
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing the 65 year old was running
around her family's 500 acre Tennessee
farm slamming Doris
pumpkin warns and just being the little
daddy's girl yeah whoo let's go show him
you Roger buck now that Miley just
released her 13th album younger now
let's just say the former Hannah Montana
star is reportedly 360 million dollars
richer thank you to album sales and
sold-out concerts
she's also back on the voice and she's
back with former fiance Liam Hemsworth
yeah we're you know super happy more
than anything is like he you know he is
my my best friend
but what are some of the things you
didn't know about the girl who was
actually born destiny Pope Cyrus Miley
because you were smiley and they dropped
yes yes drop the yes cuz I wasn't ready
for my parents be screaming smiley Miley
out the window cuz what they do by
themselves at home so I was ready just
to keep it just smiling some of the
things I want to do I want to swim in
the Red Sea I want to fly a helicopter
own a yacht I want to see the Great Wall
of China go to Australia and through the
toilet flush the opposite way I want to
write a book I want to meet Chris Martin
from Coldplay
[Music]
I'm a little obsessive Twitter I do like
it you can automatically clear stuff up
it's like a rumor for all the time I
have this thing called tachycardia your
body can't keep up with what you're like
what your heart is doing so your hobby
going too fast and you can't keep up
with it everyone's already like Miley
civic Miley's like Miley in your career
it's like no the more people doubt me
the more intense I am and the more
competitive I get and I really like
proving people wrong what's the craziest
rumor you've heard about yourself Miley
I'm either dead or pregnant every week
so I don't know I'm here
[Music]
um yeah that happened all naked riding
on a wrecking ball but let's rewind to
2003 the beginning of it all
an eleven-year-old mily audition to be
the BFF in Hannah Montana but got the
lean role instead what you see is what
you go at me
in 2007 Miley sparked Miley mania a
beetles like frenzy as she launched her
first tour parents were paying up to 3
grand for a ticket Miley invited ET into
her dressing room and backstage so how
many proposals do you get in the mail a
lot and she revealed a pretty big change
you like you officially legally change
your name to what Miley I always yeah so
your birth certificate done counting
jerem Italy Miley right just like my dad
Cyrus never again
[Music]
now Miley is dated Teen Wolf star Tyler
Posey Nick Jonas and patrick
Schwarzenegger but check out this
confession Miley made to us in 2009 I've
never been one to really like fall in
love with actors because you never know
what they're gonna be like in real life
it's only a character and I'd rather not
fall in with a character because it's
like not real three months later is when
Miley met Liam the co-stars fell in love
on the set of the last song will don't
you dare make this about me you and I
both know this is not my fault
once I met Liam I mean there's no
denying like if there's chemistry with
someone's chemistry with someone I'm
quite the Spitfire and there's like
always on so it's nice to have someone
that like fights back and it's you know
it's fun and justice on it and poke
spotters me I poke fun of me as I poke
fun of him and it's good I always say
she eats a lot of sushi but I think
everyone knows that she's getting over
oxy shots always I'm meaning to keep
May 2012 22 year old Liam popped the
question to 19 year old Miley with a 3.5
carat diamond ring a few months later
Miley chopped her hair and went platinum
blonde I could never see myself a long
long hair again it's so much maintenance
why did someone not take those
disgusting extensions out of my head and
tell me that they are not cute and that
we're not like early two-thousands
anymore thought that isn't the look the
long long long even now I just wish
someone would have told me I was stuck
in the past September 2013 was the
break-up with Liam reports say Miley's
raunchy VMA performance was to blame
Hemsworth was reportedly disgusted as
for dad Billy Ray Wow
I said hey baby I said proud of you
because you knew you had to reinvent
coming out of this mammoth monster known
as Hannah Montana
of course since then Miley and Liam got
back together Miley quit smoking weed
stopped drinking and revamped her image
to be younger now but whether she's hung
out with a foam finger or happy and love
in Malibu we still see the same fiery
spirit we saw in the first Miley I'm not
afraid of nothing
[Music]